PRIYANKA: Hi, I'm
Priyanka [INAUDIBLE],,
and this is AI
Simplified, where we
learn to make our data useful.
In this video, we're going
to imagine a company that
has large amount of
data which they want
to use to make
meaningful predictions,
and take their business
to the next level.
And we also know that their
team has varying levels
of machine learning expertise.
To accelerate this
AI innovation,
they are looking
at Vertex AI, which
provides tools for every step
of the machine learning workflow
from managing data sets to
different ways of training
the model,
evaluating, deploying,
and making predictions.
In this episode, let's
see the first step
of the machine
learning lifecycle,
which is the data sets.
You don't need to
worry about data sets.
If your use case
is generic enough,
you can just take advantage
of the pre-trained machine
learning APIs.
And to learn more about them,
I've included a link below.
In order to create custom
machine learning models,
we must first have
a collection of data
to train our models with.
That is what data sets are for.
Data sets make data discoverable
from a central place.
They provide the ability to
annotate and label the data
right from within the UI.
You can track the lineage
for data governance
and can compare model
metrics between the models.
Now, to create a data set,
we first select our data
and upload it, import it,
into the managed data sets.
And then we can make
modifications and use
it to start training the model.
Currently, there are four
supported data types--
image, tabular,
text, and videos.
Now, image data sets currently
support image classification,
which is where models
predict one or many labels
from an image.
Now, for example,
identifying the types of dog
treats from images of treats.
Object detection is where the
model draws bounding boxes
around the items of the image.
For example, you're
identifying the location
of different vegetables
within a picture of salad.
Image segmentation
is where the model
can assign a label to pixel
level regions in an image.
To ensure your model
performs well in production
and there's no
training serving skew,
make sure the
training images are
close to the input
your users will
send to your deployed model.
For example, if your images
are going to be low resolution,
be sure to have blurry
images, low resolution images,
in there.
Include multiple
angles, backgrounds,
and all sorts of resolutions.
It's recommended that you
include at least 1,000 images
per label.
But, you can always get
started with 10 per label.
The more examples you provide,
the better your model will be.
Now, tabular data sets
currently support regression,
where you predict a numerical
value, and classification,
where you predict a
category associated
with a particular example.
Forecasting is where the
model predicts likelihood
of sudden events or demands.
For example, you want to predict
sales over a period of time.
Now, tabular data
sets support hundreds
of columns and millions of rows.
Text data sets currently
support classification,
which is where you
assign one or more labels
to an entire document.
In a customer support
example, an email
could include classifications as
great service or a suggestion.
Now, entity extraction
is where the model
identifies custom text
entities within a document.
For example, maybe you want
to identify all the phrases
in a customer support email
that reference pricing.
Too expensive or great value.
Sentiment analysis
is to understand
the overall sentiment
expressed in a block of text.
For example, if a customer was
happy or upset or frustrated.
Now, will your
data sets currently
support classification, which
provides labeled predictions
for an entire video,
shots, and frames?
For example, in a
football game, you
would be able to label the
section with commercials
and the section with the game.
Now, action recognition
is where the model
identifies clips in the video
where specific actions occur.
For example, in a puppy football
game, the action of a dog
making a touchdown.
Now, object tracking is where
you get labels, bounding boxes,
and time stamps for objects
you want to track in a video.
For example, in
the same game, you
want to track the football's
motion throughout the video.
Now, we just covered the
basic functionality here.
I have included the link below
for more details and best
practices on data preparation.
At this point, I think we want
to see how to create and manage
the data sets in the console.
So let's dive in.
In the console, we get
to Vertex AI and click
on the data set where we
see image, tabular, text,
and video data sets for the
different objectives we talked
about earlier.
Let's try to create
an image data set.
Say we want to do
image classification.
Before we begin,
it's good to check
the Data Guide that
shows us the requirements
and recommendations.
You can import files
directly from your computer,
and they would be
stored in Cloud Storage.
We can then add the
corresponding labels
for our images in the next step.
If you already have labels,
use the Import File option
to import a CSV with your
image URLs and their labels.
The entries in the CSV would
look something like this.
If your data is not
labeled, and you
would like human
help to label it,
then you could use the
data labeling service.
Let's upload a few files here.
Once the files are uploaded,
we can create labels
and assign them to the images.
We can also analyze
the images we
have in the data set,
number of images per label
and a few other properties.
Depending on the type
of data, your options
might vary slightly.
For example, if you
look at tabular data,
you could upload a CSV
file from your computer,
from Cloud Storage, or select
a table from BigQuery directly.
Once you select the table, the
data is available for analysis.
We can see the number of
rows, columns, et cetera.
You would do the same
for a text data set.
Once uploaded, we
can see the labels
or add new labels to the data.
And we can also
analyze a data set.
The video data set
interface looks similar.
I have some labeled sports
files here for golf, cartwheel,
horse riding, and others.
That was a high
level overview of how
you can manage different
data sets in Vertex AI.
In the next video, we will look
at the next steps of machine
learning workflow to
build and train ML models.
In the meantime, let's
continue our discussion
in the comments below.
I am excited to hear all
about your ML use case
and your data sets.